[Music]
that was the Dallas Symphony Orchestra
just last night performing the score to
Jurassic Park while the movie was played
for an audience monsters like this are
happening now at music halls around the
world
Jamie wax is here with more Jamie good
morning good morning Anthony that's
right live film scoring has become a fan
favorite and a way for elite orchestras
like the Los Angeles Philharmonic to
build a new generation of fans a short
time ago in a galaxy just a freeway ride
away
eighteen thousand kids both young and
old were welcomed to the Hollywood Bowl
by a cast of characters for a theatrical
experience like no other
when the lightsabers go on and the
energy comes back to the stage there's
no way to explain them for four nights
in August the epic Star Wars scores by
composer John Williams were performed
live with the movies by the Los Angeles
Philharmonic and conductor David Newman
conductors loved to control the tempo of
what they conduct and you lose that
ability when you are performing a lot I
score yes what are the challenges of
conducting a score while the fans don't
know it's thrilling it's exactly the
opposite of what you would think it
would be
[Music]
performing film music you need to be
more aggressive in a way and that
doesn't mean loud or soft necessarily
even if it's soft
it just needs to be really focused
[Music]
Newman has composed the scores of almost
100 films his father the pioneering
Hollywood composer Alfred Newman helped
define the genre during a 20-year run as
music director at 20th Century Fox how
big is this trend right now it's huge
five years ago two companies began
taking these concerts on the road Senna
concerts produces shows in 48 countries
they've screamed gladiator in Rome at
the Coliseum
and Harry Potter at Royal Albert Hall in
London while film concerts live works
with orchestras around the world to
showcase 16 movies including six scores
composed by John Williams I think my
father's generation even John's
generation just are absolutely
flabbergasted by this no music was
always the kind of second third fourth
you know it was really looked down that
slowly began to change with Star Wars so
in 1980 orchestras are very grumpy about
playing film music they don't want to
play film music because they think it's
not very good when Williams who studied
under Alfred Newman at Fox took over the
Boston Pops
he used the orchestra to present new
compositions for the Empire Strikes Back
in the year after year he whittles away
at it teaches them what it is I think
what's happening now is unthinkable
without John actually willing to go to
the Boston Pops and deal with that you
smell something pianist Joanne Peirce
Martin has been with the LA Philharmonic
since 2001 I think it's important to
keep future generations interested and
this is one excellent way to do it and
it's beautiful music we enjoy playing
[Music]
Christopher still has been with the
orchestra since 2007 do you have some
memorable audience reactions over the
years well I think there's something to
be said for being a performer and having
people applaud that's always nice right
but when Darth Vader comes onto the
screen and you have 18,000 people booing
at you leaves a mark it's a great moment
for you these concerts may be a sign of
our times
but David Newman notes that film scoring
can be traced back to some of the great
classical composers of the 1930s all
these really famous Europeans who were
fleeing Europe come to Hollywood it's
really but they're not willing to make
the music subservient to the film so I
think that generation now seen what's
happening you know I think they would be
elated obviously Newman is encouraged
that the art form he spent a lifetime
pursuing is being enjoyed by fans not
commonly associated with orchestral
music
it is always a combination of a bunch of
moving parts to make something greater
than all the parts put together and
there's something profoundly meaningful
about that I don't know how to describe
it any other way when it works
there's nothing artistically that I've
ever come across that's like
if you're interested in finding a live
film concert the website movies in
concert lists every upcoming show around
the world and there are a lot of them
and if you're in Los Angeles John
Williams is celebrating his 40th
anniversary playing the Hollywood Bowl
with concerts this weekend
sign me up it's a brilliant idea my
goodness there is no downside to this as
everyone I've talked to my my two
favorite things film and music together
live I mean that's really cool and the
musicians are fans of this music as well
if you have to remember that this was a
lot of the way in for a lot of these
classical musicians into their
instrument into classical music where
you were telling us as as the piece was
playing that that this is actually
cheaper for the orchestras to draw
deities singing and I became used to
have to bring in a big headliner once a
year to really pay for your more your
more challenging pieces or the stuff
that you did to keep your classical
repertoire up to date and now really
this is a great experience for for
people it's it's the classical version
of the drive-in movie wow man thanks so
much for bringing it to us Jamie just
wish I was there with you go to one yeah
I'll take you